In the video that I just did,
where I try to more rigorously
prove the Gibbs free energy
relation, and that if this
relation is less than zero
then this is spontaneous.
I took great pains to make sure
that we use the proper
definition of entropy.
That every time that we said,
OK, a change in entropy from
here to here is the heat
absorbed by a reversible
process divided by the
temperature at
which it was absorbed.
And the change in entropy of
the environment is the
opposite of that and, of course,
that is equal to zero.
And I was very careful to
use this definition.
And so you might have been
asking, hey Sal, there's a
much simpler definition or
proof in my textbook.
And I don't if it's in your
textbook, but it's in some of
the ones that I've seen
and in some of the web
pages I've looked at.
Where they use a much simpler
argument that gets us
eventually to this Gibbs
free energy relation.
And I thought I would go over
it because as far as I can
tell, it's incorrect.
And what the argument tends to
go, is it says, look, the
second law of thermodynamics
tells us, that for any
spontaneous process, that delta
S is greater than zero.
I agree with that completely
right now.
And in order for delta S, and
that's delta S of the
universe, is greater
than zero.
And that means that delta S of
the system plus dealt S of the
environment is going to
be greater than zero.
and then this is the step that
you'll often see in a lot of
textbooks and a lot of websites
that I disagree with.
They'll say delta S of the
environment is equal to the
heat or, let me say, the heat
absorbed by the environment,
divided by the temperature
of the environment.
And let's just say for
simplicity that everything
here it's in some type of
temperature equilibrium.
And it tends to be when we're
dealing with stuff in our
chemistry sets in our
labs, whatever else.
But the the reason why I
disagree with this step right
here, that you see in a lot of
textbooks, is that this is not
saying anything about the
reversibility of the reaction.
You can only use this
thermodynamic definition of
entropy if you know this heat
transfer is reversible.
And when we're doing it in
general terms, we don't know
whether it's reversal.
In fact, if we're saying to
begin with that the reaction
is spontaneous, that means
by definition that it's
irreversible.
So this is actually an
irreversible transfer of heat,
which is not the definition
of entropy.
The thermodynamic definition
of entropy is a
very delicate one.
You have to make sure that it
is a reversible reaction.
Obviously, in a lot of first
year chemistry classes this
doesn't matter.
You're going to get the
question right.
In fact, the question might be
dependent upon you making this
incorrect assumption.
So I don't want to confuse
you too much.
But I want to show you that
this is not a right
assumption.
Because if you're assuming
something is spontaneous, and
you're saying, OK, the change in
entropy in the environment
is equal to the amount of heat
the environment absorbs,
divided by T-- this is wrong
because this is not an
irreversible reaction.
But let's just see how this
argument tends to proceed.
So they'll say, OK, this is
equal to delta S of our system
plus the change in heat of our
environment, divided by the
temperature of our
environment.
They'll call this for the
environment, and that of
course has to be
equal to zero.
And they'll say, look, the
heat absorbed by the
environment is equal to the
minus of the heat absorbed by
the system.
Right?
It's either the system is
giving energy to the
environment or the environment
is giving energy or heat to
the system.
So they are just going to be
the minus of each other.
So the argument would go, well
this thing I can rewrite.
This equation is the change in
entropy of the system, instead
of writing a plus Q of the
environment here, I could
write a minus Q of the system
over T is greater than zero.
And then they multiply both
sides of this equation by T
and you get T delta S of the
system minus the heat absorbed
by the system is greater
than zero.
You multiply both sides of this
by negative one and you
get the heat absorbed by the
system minus the temperature
times the change in entropy of
the system is greater than
zero-- I'm sorry, is less than
zero when you multiply both
sides by a negative, you
switch the signs.
And then if you assume constant
pressure, this is the
change in enthalpy
of the system.
So you get the change in
enthalpy minus the temperature
times delta S of the system
is less than zero.
And they say, see this shows
that if you have a negative
Gibbs free energy or change in
Gibbs free energy, then you're
spontaneous.
But all of that was predicated
on the idea that this could be
rewritten like this.
But it can't be rewritten like
that, because this is not a
reversible process.
We're starting from the
assumption that this is a
spontaneous irreversible
process.
And so you can't make this
substitution here.
And that's why in the earlier
video I was very careful not
to make that substitution.
I was very careful to say, oh,
you know, the change in
entropy of an irreversible
system that goes from here to
here is the same as the change
in entropy as an irreversible
system that goes from
there to there.
Or let me say this
differently.
The change in entropy of a
reversible system from there
to there is the same as
an irreversible system
from there to there.
Although you don't know what
goes on in between for the
irreversible.
And so that's why I made
this comparison.
This thing, and this thing are
the same, but then we compared
the heat absorbed by an
irreversible system, and we
showed that it's less than the
heat absorbed by a reversible
system because it's generating
its own friction.
And from that, we got this
relation, which we were able
to then go and get the Gibbs
free energy relation.
So, anyway, I don't want to make
a video that's too geeky
or too particular, or
kind of trying to
really pick at the details.
But I think it's an important
point to make because so much
of what we talk about,
especially in thermodynamics,
is our definition of entropy.
And it's very important we use
the correct one, and we don't
take what I would argue are
incorrect shortcuts, because
this is not the definition
of entropy right there.